cette collation difficile ce week-end
sur tout le réseau routier les uns s'en
vont les autres rentrent ralentissement
garantit un peu partout et à toute heure
alors que la france organise au liban sa
plus grosse opération d'évacuation et de
nos équipes a pu suivre un convoi
humanitaire près de la ville de tyr au
sublime en un convoi sous legging
l'américain floyd landis dément s'être
dopé en revanche elle explique qu'il
s'est saoulé la veille du contrôle
un lendemain de cuite qui a bien réussi
et une explication qui a de quoi laisser
perplexe et réunions des vieux gréements
dans le port de douarnenez cent mille
visiteurs attendus ce week-end pour un
rassemblement qui a lieu tous les deux
ans dans une heure les stones seront en
concert au stade de france 80 mille
spectateurs qui pour la plupart sont
déjà installés pas question d'arriver en
retard
voilà monsieur bonsoir c'est le week-end
il ne faut pas être sur les routes
ralentissement embouteillages bouchon
accordéon route noir au rouge avec des
heures aujourd'hui un pic de 150
kilomètres d'embouteillages en rhône
alpes
il faut dire que c'est dans ce sens des
départs que la circulation routière
avait prévu le plus de difficultés
vérification en ile-de-france julia
delage et guillaume diar courageux ou en
été ils n'ont pas écouté bison futé mais
ils s'en sortent plutôt bien
aujourd'hui sur l'a6 les bouchons sont
plutôt rares entre paris et lyon aux
aires de repos de toute façon les
vacanciers ont tous une bonne raison de
partir et même la pluie survenue en
début d'après midi ne les décourage pas
vraiment
cette partie de paris ce matin danic en
même temps l'âge et prix j'ai fait une
heure en in arms des parties à une heure
non sa base imposable ou bien un peu
plus loin juillettistes et aoûtiens font
une pause entre deux gouttes
les uns parlent des 10 km de bouchons à
lyon les autres de leurs vacances bien
méritées chassé croisé nous sommes en
location à partir de demain donc
danville journée d' avance je pense que
c'est très bien parce que demain c'est
noir de corse
donc là on est un petit peu fatigué dès
la rentrée voilà c'est pas trop dur le
retour jusqu'aux larmes à savon devient
donc la boue qui s'est un peu paris quoi
la route est encore longue mais certains
prennent leur temps au bar et demi un
sérieux de boire une bière avant de
prendre le volant alors 0,25 pour avoir
0,25
vous pouvez revoir boubers medici pas de
boissons alcoolisées tant mieux
finalement il faudra aux automobilistes
toute leur attention pour affronter les
bouchons traitement et comme à chaque
week-end de forte affluence sécurité
routière en profite pour rappeler
quelques messages de prudence pour
éviter les accidents dans les
embouteillages il faut respecter les
distances de sécurité reportage au nord
de bordeaux sur l'autoroute à nice
françois privat et alain taris cran
l'a10 au nord de bordeaux message à
l'appui une voiture d'interception
rapide de la gendarmerie traque le non
respect des distances de sécurité
manifestement le deuxième poids lourd et
une distance
insuffisamment grande par rapport aux
pluies qui précèdent la distance minimum
et de normalement 50 m là il y avait à
peine dix mètres entre les deux camions
aussi tout le chauffeur prix en foot est
intercepté un jour de grand départ ce
professionnel de la route reconnaît
quelques difficultés à s'adapter au flot
de circulation
c'est plus compliqué parce qu'il ya des
ralentissements du coq faire attention
vous êtes les avoir battus souvent un
peu trop près autre comportement
générateur d'accident le changement
intempestif de fil sans déclencher son
clignotant
ça entraîne une amende à 135 euros et
meyer avait à 90,06 la personne s'en
acquittent de suite ou dans les sept
jours et c'est également ce type d'art
autres de points sur son permis conduire
et en l'occurrence dans le cas trois
points des pneus sous ou sur gonflés
peuvent éclater et pour la remorque de
ce véhicule les gendarmes constatent 200
kilos de surcharge sapporo pointé les
problèmes au niveau de l'adhérence peu
le véhicule est lourd plus la distance
de freinage est longue et ainsi que les
pneus peut exploser à tout moment
petits conseils aux automobilistes qui
vont prendre la route dans les
prochaines heures
lorsqu'on a une journée de travail
derrière soi on va être fatigué la nuit
après minuit et sur la deuxième partie
de la nuit on va absolument pas être
dans les meilleures conditions pour
conduire vitesse excessive ceinture
oublié ou portable au volant etc ces
futurs vacanciers sont très surveillés
et pour arriver à l'heure prévue
beaucoup choisissent le train mais avant
de s'installer dans la fraîcheur de
wagons climatisés
il faut affronter l'accueil de la gare
ce qui n'est pas toujours une sinécure
comme le montre ce reportage gare de
lyon à paris de séverine lebrun et
bernard connor il faut de la ténacité
beaucoup de patience et une forte
résistance à la chaleur
pourtant les preuves de la gare bondée
attire de plus en plus de familles
soucieuses de voyager en toute
tranquillité
pas de chaleur pas d'embouteillage moi
j'ai pas envie de conduire à la pendant
six heures tout seul que j'ai pas de
relais la formule pas de femmes donc
c'est plus facile pour m'apprendre un
chauffard de paris j'arrive à avoir fait
sens c'est beaucoup puissant mais quand
il y à un billet à composter pour chaque
membre de la famille ça peut revenir
cher 60 euros en moyenne pour un
paris-marseille
alors entre le train et la voiture il
faut faire son petit calcul
l'essence est très cher on a fait le
calcul en fait en niveau fatigue confort
et puis avec la carte enfant plus ça
revenait vers le meilleur moyen de
voyager moins cher c'est encore
d'anticiper
d'une façon générale il faut s'y prendre
à l'avancé si on veut avoir accès par
exemple la détermination de choses comme
ça
éventuellement le faire depuis internet
chez soi ce qui permet d'en avoir
parfois des promotions qui sont
extrêmement intéressante
en tout cas c'est sûr il y en a qui vont
bien en profiter
et
mais sa voiture
8 face à la belgique ce week end un
million et demi de français prendront le
train pour partir en vacances ou en
revenir et en matière de prévisions de
circulation notre ami bison futé qui a
dépassé les 30 ans de bons et loyaux
services et parfois atteints de myopie
ces prévisions sont aléatoires il est
vrai que l'homo automobilus est de plus
en plus imprévisible et qu'il sort de
nuit comme de jour
reportage de mallory ahounou et valérie
la bonne c'était il ya un an
un dimanche 31 juillet classé rouge par
bison futé et pourtant ça roule
correctement les optimistes pourront
toujours affirmé que les conseils de
circulation ont été entendus ce 20
juillet 2002 en revanche plus difficile
de justifier le rater prévu rouge orangé
le week end se révèle noir monsieur
bonsoir beaucoup plus de monde que prévu
sur les routes de france aujourd'hui
notre indice national manquerait-il de
flers
il faut dire qu'à sa création il ya 30
ans les choses étaient plus simples il
se concentrait sur le chassé croisé des
visages pâles au départ et des
peaux-rouges juillettistes sur le retour
aujourd'hui pour les spécialistes les
français sont bien plus imprévisibles
les déplacements si on peut multiplier
les faits de rtt permet d'agrandir
certains week-ends même en dehors des
ponts donc on a tous ces phénomènes
effectivement qui sont à prendre en
compte
et puis on a une réactivité aussi
beaucoup plus importantes sont de tous
les âges et aux conditions
météorologiques aux possibilités qui
peuvent être offertes aussi par les
organismes de loisirs de vacances
l'hôtellerie cette année par exemple les
fortes chaleurs ont poussé les français
à prendre la route plus tard voire à
conduire la nuit il faut donc s'adapter
bison futé intègre désormais ces
comportements dans les projections de
trafic et s'ajuste en temps réel grâce
aux nouvelles technologies
le serveur vocal site internet terminaux
gps autant de relais d'information en
2005 bison futé a estimé que 89 % de ces
prévisions étaient exacts pour demain
n'espérez pas échappé à la journée noire
le samedi du chassé-croisé est
historiquement le plus encombré
et on nous retrouverons julia delage en
direct bonjour bonsoir julia vous êtes
sur l'air de nemours à 110 km de paris
alors comment ça se présente
bonsoir et bien ce week-end commence
plutôt bien sur les routes de france
quelques ralentissements tout de même
sur l'actif au tour de lyon et de
valence où il y aurait encore une
dizaine de kilomètres de bouchons sur
l'a10 ce sont des accidents qui ont
ralenti le trafic mais sans générer de
gros embouteillages
néanmoins c'est 'qui des deux heures du
matin et surtout la journée de demain
s'annonce encore très difficile sur ce
point le conseil de bison futé est très
simple pour demain évitez de circuler ce
jour merci pour ces conseils julien et
puis pour ceux qui partent en vacances
rappelle de prudence cette année en un
mois et demi près de 200 personnes sont
mortes noyées en france pour un total de
573 accident ou prudence donc
l'essentiel de ces noyades ont eu lieu
en mer et concerne les plus de 45 ans
florence bukiya junia beaumont et
nathalie gallet une scène dramatique qui
se produit trop souvent sur les côtes
françaises
victime d'un malaise en pleine baignade
cette estive en ag à quelques dizaines
de mètres de la plage
quarante minutes durant les secours
tentent de le réanimer en vain pour les
sauveteurs la prévention de ces ex d'eau
serait pourtant simple
les gens qui vont qui ont fait un gros
repas ou qui ont bu un petit peu plus
que d'habitude dans le faire attention
face et de trois heures à se reposer
avant d'aller à l'eau et est souvent se
mouiller avant d'aller à l'eau souvent
ce que ne font pas les gens ils partent
en courant il proche d'un coup ce qui
fait que ça produit un choc thermique
les chiffres de l'institut de veille
sanitaire sont alarmants en 56 jours du
1er juin au 26 juillet 573 personnes ont
été victimes de noyades accidentelles
dont 34% mortels 51 % de ces noyades ont
lieu en mer 59 % de ces accidents
touchent les baigneurs de 45 ans et plus
ils surestiment leur condition physique
ou pensent connaître trop bien la mère
pour qu'elle leur joug de sales tours
enfin un enfant de moins de 13 ans est
victime tous les deux jours de noyade
accidentelle
heureusement pas forcément mortelle la
plupart du temps ces accidents sont dus
à un défaut de surveillance des adultes
au liban les bombardements
s'intensifiaient l'aviation israélienne
a multiplié ses raids tuant quatorze
personnes aujourd'hui un obus est même
tombé près d'un convoi humanitaire qui
évacuer des civils du sud liban une de
nos équipes étaient sur place
soyez leur reportage loïc de la mornais
et olivier robert plus que quelques
kilomètres avant la ligne de front ce
matin un habitant de tirs a réuni une
trentaine de voitures objectif aller
récupérer les gens de son village de
yaroun situé au coeur des combats avec
d'autres journalistes nous nous joignons
au convoi après avoir donné notre
position aux forces israéliennes qui
bombarde la zone
caché dans la verdure les combattants du
hezbollah tir de ses bananes rêve sur la
route un lance-roquette grapo du
hezbollah au vent pointée vers israël
est prêt à l'emploi
piégé dans cette région les habitants
nous interpelle vous allez où emmener
nous en bas à 200 m cette route blanche
marque la frontière israélienne
tous contre côté libanais voici le
village de remettre tout le secteur est
pilonnée notre arrivée suscite beaucoup
d'espoirs brace est un village chrétien
à peu près épargnés des milliers de
musulmans chiites des villages alentour
s'y sont réfugiés on vient d'achab on
est là depuis 14 jours
on a laissé les vieux derrière certains
mort sont encore sous les décombres
on a pu ramener que sept corps ici cette
femme raconte que sa belle mère était
malade
ils ont appelé la croix-rouge mais
l'ambulance n'a pas pris le risque de
venir ici sa belle mère est morte hier
c'est un prêtre chrétien qui a rendu la
prière sur son corps car il n'y a plus
d' imam certains chauffeurs de taxi se
sont introduits dans le convoi il
demande 400 $ par personne pour sortir
les habitants de la zone
c'est normal de demander autant à des
réfugiés en temps de guerre écoutez moi
j'ai risqué ma vie pour venir
certains demandent jusqu'à 1000 dollars
l'organisateur du convoi est prise à
partie il a du mal à expliquer qu'il
veut ramener les gens de son village pas
ce d'ici mais tous ses plans s'écroule
la route vers yaroun est devenue trop
dangereuse il faut faire demi tour
le malheur des uns fait le bonheur des
autres le convoi repart embarquant les
réfugiés de remettre
pour nous comme pour les réfugiés la
route s'arrête ici les bombardements ont
repris un peu plus loin
70% des habitants de la région ont déjà
fui ceux qui restent ici sont les plus
pauvres incapables de s'offrir leur
exfiltration
ils vont désormais devoir souffrir du
manque de nourriture et d'eau la france
de son côté organise aujourd'hui la plus
grande opération d'évacuation dans le
port de beyrouth près de 2000 personnes
devraient être rapatriés par quatre
navires de guerre elle devrait arriver à
larnaca à chypre demain matin la france
a déjà évacué 8500 personnes dont 6700
français et puis au 17e jour de ce
conflit ce sont les civils qui sont les
principales victimes de ces
bombardements
le nombre de morts s'élève à 459 au
liban et à 51 en israël est aujourd'hui
près de 800 mille personnes ont fui le
sud liban les nations unies ont même
décidé d'évacuer certaines positions de
leurs observateurs de la finul
quatre d'entre eux y ont été tuées mardi
par des bombardements israéliens
une escalade qui préoccupe gravement la
communauté internationale seuls les
états unis s'opposent un cessez-le-feu
immédiat
george bush se déclarent plutôt partisan
d'une force multinationale pour
acheminer l'aide humanitaire ce matin
jacques chirac a réuni les ministres
concernés réclamer une résolution du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
qui pourrait se réunir lundi à new york
et puis sur le front militaire le
hezbollah a résisté intensifie ses tirs
sur israël pour la première fois des
roquettes à plus longue portée ont été
tirés et tandis que toute cette zone
s'enfonce dans la guerre en israël les
populations s'enfermant les abris
charles enderlin émoussé arme un aria ce
matin l' alerte a été levée pendant
quelques heures et la municipalité en a
profité pour distribuer de la nourriture
aux habitants ne sont pas partis
s'installer hors de portée du hezbollah
à l'entrée de la brique pour améliorer
l'ordinaire
tami a cuisiné un couscous avec les
moyens du bord
pour les enfants c'est un vrai plaisir
un repas à l'air libre et cela ne dure
pas longtemps
des hauts parleurs demandent à tous de
retourner dans les ordres
deux explosions ont retenti une roquette
est tombée à 200 mètres de la maison
chance il n'y a pas de blessé et les
locataires de l'immeuble reprennent leur
longue attente dans la fête la nuit
vingt-cinq personnes dorment ici
frustrant de rester ici 24 1 124 112 100
la cuisine familiale on se querelle
entre nous juste pour passer le temps
faute de moyens ces familles ne peuvent
pas partir se réfugier dans le centre du
pays nous envient sur un seul salaire on
n'a pas beaucoup d'argent et où survit
grâce à la solidarité dans cette région
des centaines de milliers d'israéliens
vont passer leur dix huitième nuit dans
les abris c'est en effet l'escaladent
pour la première fois le hezbollah a
tiré un missile porter de 100 kilos
d'explosifs sur une ville israélienne
par chance il n'y a pas eu de victime
en france un sdf de 46 ans qui aurait
violé dix sept femmes à paris a été
confondu par son empreinte adn
il a été arrêté mardi gares de lyon
explications jérôme soûlard et samuel
metz mohamed witschi 45 ans un violeur
en série présumé qui aurait fait au
moins dix sept victimes ces douze
dernières années
un sdf de la capitale interpellé ce
mardi par les enquêteurs de la police
judiciaire
son mode opératoire toujours le même
dans le quartier de république il rentré
par effraction dans les domiciles de ces
victimes des femmes de 17 à 74 ans il
attendait le retour et les violer avec
une extrême violence
les enquêteurs avaient retrouvé des
preuves de sa présence sur les lieux des
cheveux ou du sperme mais on ne
connaissait pas son identité
c'est en février dernier que tout
bascule arrêté pour un cambriolage et
mises en garde à vue il
by un prélèvement de salive son
empreinte génétique va le confondre
désormais le tous les commissariats
lorsqu'ils ont quelqu'un qui est placé
en garde à vue vont pouvoir faire une
une extraction de l'adn et ils vont donc
recueillir vont recueillir de la salive
qui sera ensuite analysées aux fins
d'être envoyée au fichier des empreintes
génétiques
le problème dans cette affaire de viol
c'est le délai de traitement des
échantillons prélevés en février la
salive du suspect n'a été traitée que la
semaine dernière
entre temps deux autres femmes ont été
violées le fichier national des
empreintes génétiques est en pleine
construction il contient 250 milles
profils de personnes mises en cause
mais des milliers d'échantillons sont
encore en attente de traitement
le code adn une arme fiable à 99 % qui
devrait permettre rapidement de résoudre
des dizaines d'affaires de meurtre ou de
viol
aujourd'hui encore non élucidées à
bobigny ce soit près de 800 personnes
ont défilé dans une marche silencieuse à
la mémoire de yamine djerroud ce jeune
homme de 19 ans frappé à mort et
abandonné dans une cave
il semble qu'il était est victime d'un
règlement de comptes après un différend
à propos d'une jeune fille elle a été
mise en examen alors qu'un autre jeune
homme soupçonné d'être l'un des auteurs
a été écroué
un troisième jeune est activement
recherché par les services de police
l'américain floyd landis se défend de
s'être dopé en dépit des analyses
révélant un taux de testostérone
anormalement élevés c'est après sa
remontée spectaculaire lors de l'étape
de morzine que ce contrôle a été fait
feuilles de l'indicent affirme lui qu'il
n'a rien pris des is it
mais il admet s'être saoulés la veille à
la bière et whisky une cuite en guise de
préparation une étape de montagne c'est
en tout cas une première dans l'histoire
du tour de france stéphane breitner
dorothée cochard et michael caine
depuis deux jours floyd landis ne
s'était confié qu aux médias américains
et encore par téléphone
c'est à l'heure c'est devant les
journalistes du monde entier qu'il a
tenté de justifier une fois de plus son
contrôle positif à la testostérone
depuis que je fais du cyclisme mais taux
de testostérone est dépité ce toit
sterone ont toujours été très élevé je
voudrais donc être très clair à aucun
moment je ne me suis dopé mais alors
comment expliquer son contrôle positif
24 heures avant floyd landis est un
coureur à l'agonie dans les pentes de
joux plane
le lendemain c'est un vainqueur
implacable à morzine panache disaient
les sportifs sans doute dopage répond
des médecins le premier contrôle du
laboratoire spécialisé de châtenay
malabry est formel son taux de
testostérone est anormalement élevé et
l'hormone n'est pas naturelle elle a
donc était administré au coureur
américain floyd landis a donné les
explications les plus diverses aux 1 il
a raconté qu'il avait abusé d'alcool la
veille du contrôle et que cela aurait pu
augmenter son taux aux autres il a
surtout parlé d'un traitement hormonal
pour soigner sa thyroïde
il faut savoir que la testostérone est
relativement peu utilisés comme
médicaments
excepté dans les problèmes sexuels chez
le jeune enfant ou éventuellement chez
des grands brûlés ou décider des
vieillards dénutri alors s'il s'agit
bien de dopage avec ce produit
il aurait nécessairement était prévu à
l'avance c'est une substance qui qui
demande un certain temps pour manifester
ses effets sur le plan musculaire sur le
plan du métabolisme
donc je dirais à l'échelle de plusieurs
jours voire semaines en tout état de
cause si floyd landis se soigner à base
de testostérone
il aurait dû le déclarer à la direction
du tour de france il ne l'a apparemment
pas fait dans 10 à boucler le tour de
france and et s moyenne de 48 8 km heure
ce qui en fait un des champions les plus
rapides de l'histoire des performances
qui jette évidemment le doute sur la
capacité à s'imposer sans tricher
nathanaël de rincquesen avec stéphanie
larose
du côté de morzine la route de joux
plane à garder des souvenirs du tour
quelques couleurs il reste même des
spectateurs il y a eu ce jour floyd
landis passé ici en vainqueur et en
vitesse c'est impressionnant quand on
voit la vitesse augmente il passe là on
les voit à peine
pendant trois semaines lundi s'est
dépensé sans compter
3657 km sur les routes de france à la
vitesse moyenne de 40 km/heure 800 c'est
pas le record de l'épreuve
mais le tour de l'indicé l'un des plus
rapides de l'histoire toujours plus fort
toujours plus vite
dans l'alpe d'huez 21 virages 11 km de
côtes avec une pente à huit et demi pour
cent et lundi ce qui termine au sprint
une rôle de père il a poussé pendant
huit minutes entre la c5 et la c1 des
puissances qui était supérieure à celle
de lance armstrong lors de ses grandes
victoires et qui était supérieur à des
puissances où l'on sait très bien
qu'elle était développé pendant les
années epo n 10 a dévoré l'alpe d'huez
en 38 minutes et 36 secondes presque
aussi bien qu'armstrong mais encore loin
de pantani la référence sur cette
distance de drôle d'exploit qu'il est
sceptique ça devient froid assez
inquiétant pour le cyclisme mondial de
deux décès à penser qu'il ya encore
cette volonté en permanence de passer
plus de temps à essayer de tricher
qu'elle s'y est de se préparer
voilà et c'est mon sentiment aujourd'hui
lundi ce n'est qu'un tricheur présumés
mais son maillot jaune n'a jamais semblé
aussi pâle chez hewlett packard a
grenoble le plan social qui avait
provoqué une vive controverse en
septembre 2005 suscite un engouement
inattendu il y a plus de candidats au
départ volontaire que prévu tant les
conditions mises en place par le
constructeur informatique sont
alléchantes reportage benoît gadret et
jean claude martin c'est son dernier
jour de travail chez hewlett packard
après sept années de collaboration sur
le site de grenoble cet ingénieur a
décidé de reprendre une entreprise
l'opportunité est trop belle et je ne
voulais pas la rater 46 ans une récente
vingtaine d'années à travailler pour moi
c'est une nouvelle carrière qui se
profile devant mon
et donc je n'ai pas hésité une seconde
quand j'ai appris les conditions de
départ d'associer d'âge et len valjas
elle aussi a décidé de sauter le pas
pour réaliser un projet qui lui tenait à
coeur devenir infirmière pour cette
année d'ancienneté
elle perçoit une indemnité de 70 mille
euros soit deux années de salaire
l'idée a fait son chemin j'avais
vraiment envie de partir et d'envisager
la suite avec cette prime de départ
c'est sûr que ça permet de voir l'avenir
vraiment sereinement
près de mille volontaires pour le départ
137 de plus que ce que prévoyait le plan
social et pourtant elle annonce des
suppressions d'emplois il ya huit mois
les salariés avaient manifesté
aujourd'hui beaucoup préfèrent partir se
demande s'il y aura un autre plan social
qui viendra par la suite on ne sait pas
quelles seront les conditions est ce que
ce sera du volontariat
est ce que les conditions de volontariat
600 et sauront aussi intéressante que
cette fois ci les conditions de départ
sont en effet avantageuse avec une
indemnité en moyenne de trois années de
salaire des aides à la formation et à la
création d'entreprises
le paradoxe est qu avec cet excédent de
départ hewlett packard a décidé
d'embaucher 80 personnes d'ici 2007 à
signaler parmi les 11 prévus au 1er août
la rémunération du livret à qui est
passé de 2 25 à 2 75 % le livret
d'épargné populaire passera 3 75 mais le
plan d'épargné logement reste inchangé
les cliniques privées dont les
chirurgiens obstétriciens et
anesthésistes sont en grève depuis lundi
ont dû sérieusement réduire leurs
activités les aviez bertrand la ministre
de la santé a reçu les praticiens
grévistes
même s'il a rappelé qu'il ne pouvait
jouer qu'un rôle de médiateur avec les
assureurs
les primes ont en effet encore augmenté
de 20% cette année pour faire face à la
recrudescence de recours juridiques
intentées par les patients le conseil
constitutionnel a invalidé un article du
projet de loi sur les droits d'auteur
sur internet
défendu par renaud donnedieu de vabres
et qui avait valu quelques débats
houleux à l'assemblée nationale le
conseil constitutionnel maintient les
pénalités pour téléchargement illicite
pénalités qui peuvent aller jusqu'à la
prison explications bruno timsit et à la
location qu'il était le ministre de la
culture vous l'êtes un texte qui
respecterait les droits d'auteur et
allait gérer les peines encourues par
les internautes
et le projet de loi a été censurée par
le conseil constitutionnel pour les 8
millions de français qui téléchargent
illégalement sur internet
c'est un retour à la case départ oubliez
les 38 euros damende prévue par le
projet de loi pour un téléchargement
oublier les 150 euros damende pour la
mise à disposition de fichiers désormais
jusqu'à 300 mille euros d'amendé et
trois ans de prison pour tous les
pirates du net
ce seront donc les peines prévues pour
de la contrefaçon qui s'appliqueront dès
peine théorique jusqu'à présent les
internautes condamnés par les tribunaux
ce nom écopé que de quelques milliers
d'euros d'amendé pour que ceux qui
téléchargent pour leur usage personnel
ne soit pas trop lourdement sanctionné
le gouvernement doit adressé une
circulaire aux parquets leur demandant
une application des peines
proportionnées à sanary-sur-mer les
forains qui se sont installés nuitamment
dans le centre ville
en dépit de l'interdiction du maire
occupe le terrain et entendent bien
faire tourner manège l'amérique et ne
veut plus accueillir la fête foraine a
pris un nouvel arrêté interdisant au
public de s'y rendre
l' affaire s'annonce donc difficile
yannick à rossi et michel comme un
dernier essai avant l'ouverture dès 21h
le public pourra profiter de la vue
imprenable depuis la grande roue ainsi
que de la soixantaine de manèges
présents sur l'esplanade de sanary les
forains décidé à ouvrir coûte que coûte
l'électricité a été coupée mais des
groupes électrogènes sont sous
protection policière le maire de sanary
est également déterminé il a interdit
l'accès de la fête au public
il faut que j'assure d'une part la
sécurité des usagers qui seraient
susceptibles de rentrer se prennent donc
il est important que
c'est arrêté soit pris et qu'ensuite et
éventuellement les services de l'état le
fasse respecter blessures vous êtes tous
en tant que fils
cet après-midi les forains ont fait
contrôler leurs installations par un
expert en sécurité d'une entreprise
privée et déjà le public se réjouit de
l'ouverture
c'est normal pour moi je connais ça
depuis plus de 30 ans je viendrai quand
même pour les enfants et hier matin vers
4 heures les forains sont passés en
force pour s'installer un arrêté
municipal leur interdit l'accès au
parking où se tient la fête depuis 1936
en pleine saison
la saison est très grave si on loupe
deux fois à sanary ça peut être un
manque à gagner pour le mois de pour
beaucoup d'entre nous 40%
une demi compagnie de crs est toujours
présente à sanary elle aura pour mission
ce soit d'inciter le public à lire
l'arrêté municipal interdisant l'accès à
la fête foraine beaucoup plus calme au
pays basque dans la région de la soul
les gorges de kakuetta il y fait bon il
y fait frais il est fait vers cannes
ianine les randonnées sont accessibles à
tous reportage nathalie gallet et julien
moment la nature nous jours parfois de
drôles de tours ici une balade version
canyoning plantes luxuriantes haut à 4
degrés
cette bande de copains ne recherche pas
que le côté sportif permet de voir le
pays autrement un peu quoi
on a presque l'impression de voir de
l'intérieur on a l'impression d'y être
parce qu'on l'avait déjà eu un trop tôt
c'est que le pays va faire c'est pour ça
qu'on est venus ici mais c'est vrai
qu'après quand même ça vaut le coup
d'être d'être vécue en gris parce que ça
fait maintenant la marque là donc on
arrive à l'asmo il a à peu près de deux
mètres cinquante de haut et comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure
faites attention parce qu'on encadre des
groupes depuis dix ans il connaît
parfaitement le terrain et c'est ce qui
fait plaisir
oui mais voilà jennifer a - et surtout
de la faire voir différemment aux gens
de leur faire prendre conscience que
colporte qu'on a un pays qui est quand
même et de nature c'est quand même
exceptionnel ici à quelques kilomètres
de là même végétation même décor
mais cette fois-ci version randonnée les
gorges de kakuetta profonde de presque
300 mètres du coup peu d'ensoleillement
une forte humidité le lichen et la
mousse apprécié résultat de 40 espèces
végétales rares l'un des sites les plus
riches d'europe super sympa c'est très
ombragé ça peut se faire par tous les
temps c'est pas trop physique c'est très
bien cadre exceptionnel rafraîchissement
à volonté un peu glissant c'est vrai
mais ce que l'on retiendra sera sans
doute cette image d'un petit coin de
paradis
plus au nord en bretagne douarnenez
accueille jusqu'à lundi 8 sont vieux
gréements pour les 20 ans de sa fête
nautique
les visiteurs peuvent remonter sur des
bateaux et même faire un petit tour sur
l'eau
mon pu le faire et nous constaté jean
françois cirelli gabriel kamil
majestueux ce trois-mâts onglet 46
mètres de long trace son chemin à
travers les dizaines de voiliers qui ont
jeté l'ancré dans le port de douarnenez
ce week end la petite cité bretonne fait
l'amer 800 bateaux du plus petit au plus
grand du plus rudimentaires au plus
perfectionnés
sur la jetée les coeur chavire pour ses
navires enfin toutes voiles dehors ya
beaucoup de poésie aussi même pour
quelqu'un qui n'est pas
marin la beauté des couleurs là le voile
qui penche dans des directions
différentes
il ya donc ceux qui restent à quai et
puis il y a les autres comme la famille
maréchal qui embarquent à bord de
bateaux parfois centenaires ici à
homardiers madame maréchal apprend à
faire des noeuds pas facile le fiston
lui s'est découvert une vocation de
capitaine de corvette
c'est beau quand les vieux gréements
comme ça c'est un précieux bateau
c'est plus joli des modernes comment
c'est vraiment une fête qui est très
très convivial je pense que ça se sent
sur les sur les quais c'est une fête de
marins avant tout et à chaque fête de
marins ces chants de marins et ses
bateaux star les goélettes le pen duick
du skipper français eric tabarly ou ce
cotre corsaire du 19e siècle les marins
bretons aiment faire revivre les navires
de légende
cet après-midi la réplique d'une
ancienne chaloupe bretonne a été mise à
l'eau pour la première fois la fête à
douarnenez a été lancé sous les
applaudissements et c'était hier la
soirée de clôture du festival d'avignon
une 60e édition plus consensuelle que
celle de l'an dernier
il est vrai que l'hommage à jean vilar
fondateur du festival ne pouvait que
réconcilier tous les défenseurs de
théâtre vivant reportage isabelle
bechler et bruno vignais 60 ans après
les débuts du festival tout avignon
bruit de théâtre et nous points partout
l'héritage de jean vilar infuser la
ville peu après la guerre c'est lui qui
avait tenté de faire du théâtre un
divertissement un éblouissement
populaire le faire sortir en tout cas du
ghetto bourgeois
énorme elle hilare est le personnage
central du spectacle d'olivier py c'est
à avignon qu'il nous fut donnée de
vérifier que le seul véritable avenir du
théâtre était dans un théâtre populaire
il nous faut remettre et réunir dans les
travées de la communion dramatique
le petit boutiquier de suresnes et les
hauts magistrats
l'ouvrier de plus tôt et l'agent le
change le facteur des pauvres et le
professeur agrégé à la maison jean vilar
une exposition s'attache à sa relation
avec les publics on y retrouve les
témoins des premiers jours et ça c'est
au comédien en disant s'il ya qu un seul
ouvrier au fond d'la de la fal donc la
cour il faut penser que vous adressez à
lui le succès fut tel en avignon qu'à
paris on lui offrit chaillot le tnp
dès 1951 maintenant il faudra vous
habituer à être détesté jean vilar
l'acteur le metteur en scène
enthousiaste et infatigable doutait
aussi pour les ouvriers mais moi je les
connais pas les ouvriers son engagement
artistique fut soutenue par malraux son
engagement social fut critiquée à gauche
par sartre par les révoltés de 68
olivier py a trouvé des textes inédits
archivés par villar lui même
je dois tout au festival d'avignon je
suis vraiment un enfant d'avignon
villard est un personnage méconnu parce
que trop connu le lieu-même lui a
soufflé à l'oreille d'une certaine idée
du théâtre populaire une certaine idée
d'un lien entre le théâtre et la nation
le théâtre populaire pour donner de
l'émotion à tout un chacun
tant que les hommes se grime rond pour
monter sur une scène entre genre de
mythes populaires les rolling stones
c'est dans une heure au stade de france
un concert en partenariat avec france 2
80000 spectateurs impatients de
retrouver leur groupe mythique et parmi
eux vincent fourcade et janvier melun
dur métier parfois un dernier contrôle
et dans moins d'une heure les fans ont
rendez vous avec l'autoproclamé plus
grand groupe de rock du monde ça fait
plaisir
après huit ans d'absence les stoned sont
de retour au stade de france face à eux
80 mille personnes venues écouter les
tubes qui ont bâti leur légende brunch
gars qui tant que mâle jumping jack
flash
31e pour les mondiale des rolling stones
et déjà quatre millions et demi de
spectateurs au compteur depuis 40 ans
ils remplissent les stades et maintenant
c'est en famille que l'on vient célébrer
lé roi du rock'n'roll
ma chanson préférée cpnt fnac
je suis le film emma sont empressés
mamoun chanson préférée c'est une
pratique mais les papiers du rock 249 en
a eu quatre sont également des rois du
marketing pas un groupe au monde ne
gagne autant d'argent que ils sont
d'ailleurs parmi les plus chers de 80 à
150 euros la place de concert ce soir
normal politique normale après le bris
il faudrait qu'on les agresse un peu
aussi pour ce prix là et malgré la
soixantaine passée les rolling stones
assure toujours le spectacle le démon du
rock'n'roll est toujours en eux s'ils
terminent ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi tout de suite la météo valérie
alexandre suivi de l'indispensable point
route de juin pascal excellente soirée
sur france 2 je vous retrouve demain à
13h on soit